president biden getting more desperate
after failing to gaslight the american
people into thinking that putin is
behind higher gas prices now
he's resorting to teenage tick tock
stars to push his price hike propaganda
i had the opportunity to ask the white
house why gas down the street is seven
dollars and here's what they said russia
is one of the top three producers of oil
and it is actually their number one
revenue source now with putin starting
this horrific fight between ukraine and
russia nobody wants to work with him and
do an international trade
and transportation secretary pete
buttige isn't even focused on the
surging gas prices
gas prices are famously something that
is largely outside of the direct control
of any political figure
[Laughter]
where do you laugh oh just pete uh the
spin is so hard
greg yes are you now convinced
everything is okay after watching that
tick-tock propaganda i was sitting
around going like could there be a move
that's any more unserious than sending
kamala to poland what could it be what
could be why not use an app favored by
12 year olds that's created by china
that is mang infiltrated and mangled so
many adolescent brains this it's funny
you know that i was thinking about this
tik tok might be the most effective
cyber warfare in history because it's in
every house it it causes kids to do
really bad stuff to each other and to
others sometimes it's self-mutilation
it's basically delivering crap to our
kids brains meanwhile in china they use
tick-tock to educate their kids they
have rules they go i mean it's like and
yet we're polluting ourselves but it's
just again it it it shows you how
unserious we are about ending this war
it's amazing boris
johnson the guy whose hair looks like
somebody dumped a bowl of linguine on it
he's on top of the energy question he's
meeting with these meeting with the oil
people the gas people because he's not
concerned with pleasing 20-somethings
you go by they and them we're meeting
with
teenagers
on social media sandra i don't know uh
does it say that
i guess biden doesn't have any real
fixes he's just worried about pr
if he does he hasn't broadcast them or
said what they are jensaki was asked
about it again today in the white house
press briefing and her answer is always
that this is a priority for him to
address these price bikes for the
average american consumer it is painful
they acknowledge that and say that all
options are on the table we still don't
know what those options are i speak to
the oil and gas industry i ask them what
could be done to increase and
incentivize
more drilling obviously more oil
production to bring those gas prices
down if you were to think about
something really reasonable to hear from
this administration
the oil and gas industry the american
petroleum institute says just send a
friendlier message that you're not out
to demonize the oil companies and now
you've got these two democrats sheldon
uh white house and roacana they want to
tax the oil companies more and a moment
where we actually
need them we need more oil production to
bring and by the way the message to the
tick tock viewer out there is green
energy and a moment where 65 of the
american people are living paycheck to
paycheck they're telling you on tick
tock to go buy an ev you know what the
average price of an electric vehicle is
today
brain room says 60 000
and tesla just raised their prices
because of all the supply chain problems
geraldo aye aye are you are are you now
on board with the putin price hike after
watching that young lady tell you that
that's better
that definitely put me over the top uh i
i concede that president
biden blew it when he crushed domestic
oil production i think that that was a
that was a strategic era regardless of
the uh of the tiktakian
presentation there biden should admit
that he made a terrible error but this
sandra smith is also true
exxon chevron bp and shell
are all enjoying the highest profits
they have in seven and a half years
what's your point
my point is that the oil companies are
reaping record
profits
some of this
could be handed to the consumers rather
than companies exxon chevron bp
i mean why don't we look to them and say
why doesn't the government cut the gas
tax then but the gas tax is the only
thing that keeps the highways together
but
many politicians of various stripes have
pondered cutting off the uh the excise
the gas tax and all comes to the same
conclusion it's reckless and
irresponsible
let me just ask you a question are you
suggesting that those companies are
engaging in illegal activity by falsely
propping up gas prices because if you
are they should be held accountable but
if they are then evidence should be
provided because that's a big claim i am
suggesting that the oil companies are
reaping windfall profits and ro khanna's
suggestion of a windfall profits tax is
much more viable to me than getting rid
of the you own stock
energy companies i do yes he does okay
so you're getting your thoughts the only
people are making windfall profits are
russia
and venezuela is about to make some but
let me just comment on the tick tock
first i never thought anything could be
more ridiculous than when kamala harris
had those young child actors help her in
that space video remember where you
could see with your own eyes the moon
remember that one
i also wanna but i also wanna talk about
a segment of our population that we
haven't talked about and that's the
senior citizens so if the alternative to
the biden administration is we're not
going to drill here we're not going to
loosen up but the regulations we'll go
to we'll go to venezuela we'll beg the
saudis although they won't take our call
um and we want we want electric cars
senior citizens drive cars with internal
combustion engines they cannot afford an
electric car and unless the government
wants to give them a voucher for an
electric car
with their next social security check
they're not they're the ones who are
lost in all of this they are on a fixed
income they cannot afford anything they
can't even think about an electric
vehicle so while we're going la da da da
da da why don't we consider our parents
our grandparents the people who fought
the wars who built the streets they're
being crushed while this president only
cares about tick-tock can i just get
this one last point in there because the
white house and the democrats like to
tout the 9 000 leases that are not
getting tapped into they're not drilling
they've got the permits issued but then
create a friendlier environment for
those energy companies to drill because
if they drill guess what they have to do
spend those profits
make sense
i'm all poor i'm all i don't see why
just because you are in favor of a green
future you can't do practical i'm a
pragmatic idealist talk to chevron exxon
bp and shell and say listen you guys are
doing great is this case
now do me a favor now capitalist society
leave malone unless they're profiteering
leave them alone they are profited all
right oh all right then go to the
department of justice
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else